any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
but i want to get just what i call rapid
fire uh
james's james's uh james's take on a
couple of business ideas we're gonna
give them away
as you love to do give away 10 million
dollar ideas on a daily basis
on instagram and on your podcast uh
first idea uh you could just do you know
kind of
roman gladiator you know thumbs up
thumbs down verbally
and by the way by the way i might be
wrong right like oh no no just this is
purely about james it's not about like
absolutely okay so we already did zoom
comedy club it sounds like that is a
good idea
um uh people are doing it not
necessarily right okay by the way
by the way i so i don't think zoom
comedy clubs are a good idea
it remains to be seen but what's
interesting there
is that happens often in innovation and
sorry this
interrupts the rapid fire flow but
what's interesting about innovation is
zoom was meant to have meetings remote
meetings with like four or five people
they didn't expect a a lockdown that
would force three billion people to
start using
zoom to do all their not only office
meetings but
zoom didn't expect there to be opera
singers doing events on zoom for
hundreds of people or comedy
events or even podcasts like zoom wasn't
really made for podcasts we're
we're we're lucky there hasn't been an
outage on either side but podcasting
software should have audio recording on
both sides and
and other features and so so there's
there's room for a lot of innovation
here and
just knowing that there's zoom events i
wouldn't make a comedy
event software but there's ideas in
there somewhere
like ticketing on top of zoom so idea
sex between
ticketing software and video
conferencing software there's there's so
there's something there for instance so
next idea is a crossover between the
show you had involvement with billions
and then you know remember back in the
70s you had like the facts of life
and uh what was the other one what's
happening and they'd have a crossover
you know we were kids and they'd be like
roger and rerun would go on with mandy
and
candy whatever their names were i used
to watch that billions and succession
would that be a show you'd want to watch
crossed over
yeah imagine imagining the family
imagine the family
is a big investor with acts with axe
capital
yeah and then um uh uh
uh you know there's a there's a little
bit of falling out because axe
pulls out of the media company you know
that that the roy family owns i forgot
the name of the media company
um so a star global or whatever right so
so
so the main guy um logan roy is the main
guy yeah logan
says to axe you know screw it i had two
billion in your fund i'm pulling it all
out
so now on the one hand axe has to scurry
around town
for for uh uh to raise money to meet
some kind of margin call
and uh now the um connor the stupid roy
he wants to start a hedge fund he thinks
he can do it and
you know his dad has to you know you
know
keep conor happy a little bit and maybe
he gives conor a little bit
in the headshot and then paul giamatti
comes in for antitrust right
right right so then axe gets back at the
roy family
for setting up connor on an insider
trading deal like
like ax says look connor you want to
impress your dad
i'm going to give you a tip play it
small be careful and then axe
leaks it to paul giamatti this guy's
connor is
doing insider trading and so that
distracts paul giamatti and it brings
down connor and it distracts logan roy
and boom you have a great episode yeah
okay so that's a thumbs up
uh next one podcast where you have
authors uh who go on and they don't know
who the host
is going to be but it's hosted by
verified purchasers on amazon who gave
the book a one-star review
ah i i like that yeah i uh i think
that's
i think that's a fun idea that would be
a good concept
but but after the first episode they'll
kind of know the setup unless what you
do is you
you you it's like a one a seasonal thing
yeah and so you do one season you record
it all in advance
and then seriously the next the next
season will be some other twist on
authorship so and it can't be like ad
hominem it has to like their name
verified name you know they can't be
trolls right right so so yeah maybe the
the um the the there's got to be a
season two season three where you change
the structure somewhere or else people
know
it could be five-star and then like some
like really awful author or something
like that but but yeah
i like the one star but it has to be
verified because it's like it's not
verified there's no stakes in it right
so anyone can say whatever they want so
natural license to troll
this way like or or next year like
anyone who comes out they have to
publish their home address or you know
right i like that as a one-season thing
i'm trying to think of like what the
second
season could be uh see if we get funding
for the first season we just have like
100 episodes in the first season
yeah release them all at once uh next
one um
least uh least uh active social media
platform for trolls
um i i think it's linkedin but what do
you think it is like
where you feel safe is to say whatever
the hell like i've never been trolled on
linkedin
uh where where do you think is the
safest place to go on like the place you
never
worry you're gonna get like you get like
stupid you know threats or stupid things
on twitter every single day
and i love the way you responded like
you're obviously so much smarter than i
am i want to subscribe to your
newsletter
and join your join your retreat but
what's the least what's the most
friendly social media platform
so by the way with the best response
again
it's all about it's all about the second
law of thermodynamics
it's like mixed with taekwondo right so
you want their energy
you want to use their energy against
them so they're attacking you so much
you just you just turn to the side like
yeah you're right how about you make all
of my tweets for me from now on
and then they're just they're just lost
then they they fell i got a comment on
my youtube like yeah why didn't you ask
this
you know it's like very click-baity and
then you know how youtube will tell you
the subscriber and how many videos and
followers they have
it's like you have you're just trying to
get followers i'm unsubscribing and the
guy had like zero phones
i was just like i was tempted to do the
altitude response like
obviously i have much to gain from you
sensei but i was like i don't have time
yeah sometimes it's not worth it because
you also don't want to lend
your the massive energy for your that
you
devoted to building your audience to
this one person with zero uh
videos up there yeah so that's that's
the challenge usually you just want to
ignore
but with least trolling yeah maybe
linkedin although i have been trolled
there
um i i don't know if there are comments
on pinterest
um i've certainly never or or you know
there's there's also starting to be
social networks where
um it's one to many so uh people could
sign up
for to be texted by me and then there's
there's
you know in order for them to do that
they're buying into my what i'm saying
so uh so far i haven't experienced
trolling on stuff like that
um okay next one has to do a little bit
with with trolling
and it's uh this concept of peer review
so we have peer review and science
uh it could be for refereed papers we
want to get them published
it could be for um it could be for a
grant proposal
and the question is uh you know we kind
of passed that like imagine
in your comedy club if all the audience
was just other comics that were going on
after like they'd be total a-holes you
know like
are yeah they wouldn't be but but can
you imagine that they would be nice but
here's what would happen is
they would be quiet because they're
thinking about their material
and they're dissecting your material
they're not you'd have to be like
exceptionally
brilliant to to get a room full of other
comedians to laugh
and also then there's some competition
and stuff but yeah those are
are uh they're not quite trolling or
heck they're not gonna heckle or
anything but they're not gonna
laugh and you they might say that's good
or
something like that they'll like uh you
know
indicate that something's funny but
they're not it's hard for them to to
laugh
do they do that i mean do you comment
comedians like like
workshop or whatever with actual other
comedians like
more than just a mentor or something
like do you ever do that would that be a
good idea like
like if you're like the lions then just
like one night close a comedy store
close stand up new york to everybody but
professional comics or or amateur yeah
or or even take like pros like uh
kevin hart he's got a team of comedians
to travel around with him and help him
with all his
jokes i mean i'm sure he's clearly he's
super funny without that but yeah that's
what for for a major performance with 30
000 people
he's got his team to help him probably
dave chappelle
is like that a little as well and uh
they're probably at that level they're
probably all
like that to to an extent yeah okay next
is this thing i sent you right before
uh we started recording uh it's this
doll
called moxie and you're a computer
scientist
uh you've done a lot of programming uh
you're also a father
and in honor of you know father's day we
started talking about this uh this
project called moxie
which if you go to their website um and
you click on it
it will say and i'll put the uh show we
have no affiliation
at least i don't maybe no no james says
let me tell you but so it's called the
revolution in child development and it's
a doll
and the kid is like perfectly you know
what beautiful kid is talking to this
this robot and the robot's asking about
his day and
it kind of made me think about like the
turing test the famous turing test
um and whether or not uh you know a
human being can determine if they're
talking to a sentient
artificial intelligence uh a turing uh
capable
um a device so what do you think about
this i'll put this in are you uh
is it creepy or or not it's creepy but
the
the interesting thing is is that there
used to be these things i think they
were called yamagachi
dolls or something like that or
tamagotchi i don't know and and
it would be like clearly not a real
human and you know you'd give it to your
child and the child had to know when to
feed it
and they put it to sleep and so on and
so
you know its idea was a fun kind of a
slightly more advanced doll
and of a teacher kid responsibility and
this is almost like a super advanced
version of that because it's got a.i and
it looks much more human-like
but you know in in both in virtual
reality there's something called um
the uh i think it's called hidden valley
uncanny valley
uncanny valley yeah where my research is
friends here works on that
yeah and and the idea is your your brain
like you're looking at it and you think
is this human and then over
a few minutes or a half hour your brain
realizes oh this is not
something i feel queasy like your brain
knows it's not human so it starts to
feel
sick physically ill like if you're ever
in a virtual reality for more than like
10 15 minutes you'll start to feel sick
like i've given talks in
virtual realities and it's just like a
very nauseating experience after a few
minutes because you realize
your brain suddenly realizes this is not
real
but i'm being told it's real so there's
this dissonance
and then the other thing is like when i
first watched that video that you showed
me
i just felt sad for the kid yeah he
didn't feel like
it didn't feel like a healthy thing it
reminded me of like that peloton
commercial where
it just felt something was off there was
like some dissonance
you know there's a pelton commercial
where this woman is just like bicycling
furiously
uh all around her family all the time
and it was like there's something
was off about how she was behaving yeah
or like people were like oh she's being
fat-shamed like her husband gave it to
her
and and that she's fat shamed and it's
like this gorgeous supermodel you know
woman
uh and i told that to one of my friends
he's not on social media there's a huge
uproar remember a couple months ago back
it's funny like all the things that
troubled us before coronary arts like
you know oh money was killed blah blah
blah that's awful whatever if you're an
iranian you know or people it's gonna
cause world war three
or peloton girl you know [ __ ] fat shame
by her husband
i told it's one of my friends who's like
anti-social doesn't even have an
account he's like you know my wife
bought me a peloton like
i love the thing like i'm hoping to drop
a couple and he's in like great shape
he's like i would love it the peloton
might be a great thing it's just like
the
ad felt weird yeah so with this with
mock with this moxie
you see in the ad you see this image or
in the video you see this image of the
parents
they like they peek in on their boy and
he's like really lonely and playing by
himself oh my hand the robot says to him
right so rather than but but it feels
sick because rather than the parents
coming in and saying
hey let's go out to the park and play
catch
it's like they think they're solving the
entire loneliness problem their kid but
that's the thing
they have enough awareness to know that
the kid needs this lack has this lacuna
in his or her life
and they have the resources and they're
tuned in enough and they trust this
thing
why don't you do it yourself like you're
a much cheaper version of moxie i agree
100
and let's say let's say they're busy
okay the moxie price for something like
1700
well that pays for a lot of babysitting
time too so is this really better than
like
humans playing with the kid even if you
don't even if the parents didn't have
time
yeah so it was just it felt it felt off
on a couple different levels
yeah i agree i think the uncanny valley
um
so let's see we're going to get to the
final couple of questions in a second
here
um so let's see next one
we talked about podcasting apps last
time let me get into
just a final uh final couple of
questions just in the speed round
is it uh is it possible or not for you
know entrepreneurs who are you know pro
could be like um you know mark
zuckerberg or whatever like really good
at programming
but there's this concept called the
peter principle where you rise to the
level of your incompetence
um you know and that i feel like with
other faculty probably myself included
you know i'm really good at physics no
one ever taught me how to be a leader
like when i have to lead a big
experiment like what how how does
leadership
really approach this concept of like you
may be good in one
huge set of meta skill like you might be
the greatest stand-up comedian in the
world doesn't mean you can run a comedy
club
um do you think that there is like an
endemic
attribute of someone who's good in a
craft like you're a really good first
baseman
doesn't mean you could be a coach like
is there a fundamental
tunneling quantum tunneling process
that's almost forbidden
for someone who's really good at some
set of very attuned meta skills
to tunnel through and get to the other
side like even jim simons he was great
at running a
department and he was great at running a
hedge fund that like in the ultimate
analysis
i think those aren't dissimilar at all
but the difference between you know zero
to one in peter thiel's language
like going from like base first baseman
to head
you know general manager that's a huge
gap or comedian great stand-up comedian
to owning and running a successful
comedy club
yeah so are you saying is it possible or
is there a technique
is there yeah is it is it um yeah is
there a technique is there
is it forbidden i guess that's the thing
yeah is it possible is it forbidden
uh it's certainly possible i mean look
at rodney dangerfield was a comedian and
he
owned a club called dangerfields and he
was successful at both dangerfield still
exists even um and i i think it's just
understanding the meta skills of
learning so um there's various you know
and by the way this assumes they have a
passion for wanting to
run a comedy club some comedians would
not want to run a comedy club sure so
let's just assume they have the passion
they want to be good at it
i could list a bunch of different
techniques as i'm sure you can but
uh frank shamrock who's one of the uh
the greatest
uh ultimate fighting champions ever he
was a world champion
in the late 90s uh he told me this
technique
find your plus minus equals so find your
mentor or virtual it could be virtual
mentors or they could be real mentors so
a virtual mentor would be
you know you read their books and
whatever um find your equal so these are
the people who are also
uh doing the same thing they're at the
same level as you
and you're you're exchanging notes
you're able to be a little bit more
honest and authentic with them like oh
i'm having problems with this but i
don't want to tell
my mentor yet like what are you doing
for this and so
so you know you grow up as like a scene
um you know like like
like the beat movement of writers jack
carrick allen ginsberg william s burrows
for the pop art movement with andy wahl
right lichtenstein um and then you find
your minus
which is and this you know very well if
you're if you're a teacher and einstein
said right if you can't
explain something simply then you don't
really understand it to begin with
and you see this even like in world
chess champions they
they often take the time out even if
they're the best player in the world
they'll take the time out to write a
very basic here's how to play chess
sort of book to kind of almost remind
themselves of the fundamentals
very good okay james i know you're super
busy i know you're going to relax and
get to rob dinner with robin let me
finish up
with we have a bunch of other things
maybe someday we can do another part two
but i wanted to
uh finish up part one and uh i want to
read to you from
your uh professor famous professor maybe
you had him
at uh at cornell it's carl sagan over
here
you know i got i got accepted to his
class and then
i decided not to take it i wish i should
have i regret it i should have taken it
well i would love to connect you with
his widow ann jurian who runs as
a director writer producer of cosmos and
it's coming up on a second season this
september 23rd and then his daughter
sasha sagan uh was my mother's day guest
as i said earlier
um and on the into the impossible
podcast and
uh the two of them are just you know i
call them the first family of the
universe they're just so brilliant
so um so carl sagan wrote um the
following he said what an astonishing
thing a book is it's a flat object made
from a tree
with flexible parts on which are
imprinted lots of funny dark squiggles
but one glance at it and you're inside
the mind of another person maybe
somebody dead for thousands of years
across the millennia an author is
speaking clearly and silently
inside your head directly to you writing
is perhaps the greatest
of human endeavors or inventions binding
together people who
never know each other citizens of
distant epochs books
break the shackles of time a book is
proof that humans are capable of working
magic
so i want you to you know first pick
your favorite of all your books um
but first pick your favorite child no
i'm just kidding i'm not going to do
either one of those
um i would never ask you to do anything
brian keating and uh
all my children are equal that's what my
mom used to say and then
she say um i can't you know she i have
three brothers she said it's like asking
me i'd say who's your favorite she said
that's like asking me to pick you know
which hand do i prefer my left hand or
my right hand mom you're left-handed
um so i forced her and i'm a wonderful
son
um i want to ask you what do books mean
to you you've obviously
written a large number some by yourself
some but with other people
i've gotten a tremendous amount out of
every one of them and i have a tie into
the next to the next one but what do
books mean to you uh how do you
react to that statement by carl sagan i
i think it's a great statement
and obviously there's for me there's two
kinds of books
and and this is obvious there's
non-fiction and there's fiction but
let's just say and let's just assume
we're all talking about just
quality books written by really smart
people and and let's for a second stick
with
non-fiction or or autobiography or
whatever
i i view it as almost like being a
vampire
like you know i read your book you've
worked
for 20 years on you know
studying the origin of the universe and
then constructing your idea
you know i get to see into your head
like you're how you're thinking about
well what if we could see these other
waves beyond
the the cosmic background radiation like
i start to think like how you're
thinking it's giving me ideas like are
the well are there other waves other
than
light gravity like i'm starting to think
well then what would you do
to sense those and then you talk about
you know how the cosmic background
radiation is not
symmetric this is your obsession earlier
with symmetry with uh
both hedge funds and the earth but it's
very much related to your research right
like
the cosmic background radiation is not
as symmetric as people thought
and this is the thing we need to detect
to see what's going on
so i chd granted phd
finally after 30 years
excellent so so i get to absorb i'm like
a vampire i get to absorb
your 25 years of work
in into my like i'm a vampire just suck
it all in just by reading your your book
it's like i drain your your your all
your
brain cells and put it in my brain and
uh uh and then every book i read is like
if it's if it's a good book i'm i'm a
vampire sucking that life
force in and all that knowledge and uh
it's it's great i get to i don't have to
be a physicist now you've lived that
life for me and then i
stole your 25 years from you by reading
your book now i'll go on to
you know the next book and uh uh with
fiction
it's a little similar but a little
different you get to um if you really
are into writing and and can see what
makes one writer different from the
other
i get to absorb their entire writing
style and
and and really now i can i'm
them i can write like them like if i
wanted to i could write like
i mean not as good as but i can mimic
like hemingway
or or thomas pynchon wouldn't be as good
as them but you would see the difference
you know between the styles and i could
point you would say oh yeah it's like
thomas pincher it's like the
minimalist or it's maximalist or
whatever and so i get to absorb their
writing styles
and it doesn't last too long that the
fiction stuff does it's like a drug and
then it wears off over time
but often before i write i re i pick out
oh i'm going to write a sensor i'll pick
out somebody who is minimalist and maybe
a little sad and uh
and absorb that style and combine it
with my own in my head and then
and then i'm writing you know at a
different level
so again it's a very vampire like
attitude towards where's books
but and then i just love reading and i
love a good story yeah and i love that
you give away all these ideas for you
know how you approach
a book both you know we talked about
later speed reading but actually you
know to get extract
some of that bone marrow that you just
talked about um you know you act it's
legitimate it's not actually oh i just
want to skim and say oh
on page 27 you use the word you know
outsourcing you know who cares but uh
but you're actually
delving in deeply into it but you had a
recent series of tweets
you know which could be a little class
on its own a tick tock or whatever on
just like
great opening lines and and you once
said something like every line in a book
has to
really impel with the gravitational
force field
you to read the next sentence and the
next sentence and and every sentence and
every structure and every paragraph next
paragraph every chapter every page yeah
and doing that and and just
relentlessly curious like you you have
to be
stimulating this and that's what makes
it so hard maybe even harder than making
somebody laugh
but um but i i just want to say that i
appreciate that very much and
it's something i resonate with well and
you know here's the thing like here
twitter's been around
whatever 14 years yeah people have been
using it
and so again i uh we've been talking
about idea sex
i've been wanting to combine the idea of
twitter with masterclass.com
so i've been doing these little and i've
just started doing this in the past
month maybe or whatever but i've been
wanting to do these little master
classes
on twitter so what you're referring to
is i did this little master class
on analyzing first lines of
great novels and just breaking them down
and
you know i did another one the other day
on um gen x
i did one a few weeks ago on what really
caused the the
the events over the past three decades
that caused the great recession of 2008.
so i'm kind of combining compiling these
twitter master classes and then
eventually
i'll print them all up i'll flesh them
out a little bit more and i've got
a book of twitter master classes about
everything yeah yeah that was a that was
a rapid fire question how do you
not i i don't like to think of you as
like monetizing it i think you're you
know it's not your but like uh idea eyes
or you know kind of
like just just synthesizing these
creative ideas that you have
but like a book is this repository as
sagan is saying
you know it's basically storing this
thing and on you know parchment or
whatever that can last for you know the
only reason we know
ryan holiday has been on your show you
know he says things like the only reason
we know about
you know what marcus really is thought i
mean this is before paper we just take
it for granted
and you know i was like um i was talking
to mary olivia who wrote a book about
curiosity who'd be a great guest for you
someday
but he was interesting yeah he's he
wrote a book called why what makes us
curious
uh and he had uh you know he wrote a new
book recently by galileo
and kind of the light of what's called
what he calls science denialism and we
went back and forth about that on my
podcast
but he um you know he's basically
talking about this book that galileo
wrote called the dialogue
where galileo foolishly put the words of
what a character called the simpleton
he used the pope urban you know who is
the the most powerful force in the
universe at that time
uh and and he put the the words of the
pope in the mouth of a character named
the simpleton simplicio
and but we're talking about it and we
were saying like i was just remarking
like
one of galileo's earlier books is called
the compass and the compass has
uh is it not a mil it's not like uh
magnetic compass it's like a
protractor you know something that used
to divide angles and it's kind of like a
primitive slide rule
and we went through this description the
book which is like an instruction manual
it's funny we don't
even have instruction manuals for any
technology we have but back then
no one would have the device but they
could print up the instruction manual
because it was very cheap to do it
and galileo goes through this conversion
like you can use the slide roll type
thing to convert between
you know scooty and venice to ducati in
florence and
going through and i was thinking like uh
if you found a ducati a ducat or
whatever it's worth
you know maybe some collector's value
but if you had the actual book it's
worth like five million dollar like
nobody has this book like if he had just
given it to his kids they'd be you know
their
heirs would be multi-trillionaires by
now just every copy printed up
yeah but it's true it's true and the
benefit of like you know it used to be
to publish a book you had to have an
agent and then you have to go through
the pathway you described for being a
professor
yeah you have an agent then a marketing
company and a book publisher likes you
the publisher likes you editor likes you
the bookstores like you
age and then finally you get the book
deal now you can
write a three-page book and upload it to
amazon and it's a book
and so there's there's millions of
self-published books out there and
and actually some of them are very high
star rankings and sell
50 shades of gray started off as
self-published the martian
right yeah the martian started off as
self-published wool which is going to be
a tv series start off as self-published
but um uh the whole point is you don't
have to
you no longer have to publish with the
goal of reaching a large audience
you might somebody listening to this
might want to just publish their story
so their great great grandkids could
know who they were and
then no other buyers just the
great-great-grandkids and speaking of
books
um so the end of uh of the power of no
is
is really touching uh and it and it um
you know
uh it's had a big impact on me what's
unique about that book
amongst all your other books is that it
kind of contains like checklists
and um more than just being a polemic or
an art you know
a manifesto it's it's actually a
step-by-step
you know atel gawande type instruction
manual a checklist
to go through like when you're feeling
stuck and down or depressed and
low energy whatever but the very end of
it uh you finally get to like
yes and getting to yes to go back to the
very beginning of this podcast
we were talking about uri erie and uh
and how i felt
uh this this orthogonal pull between you
and him
a tedx not really but uh the last ch the
last sentence is of the power of no it's
not a spoiler i don't think i can spoil
a book that's seven or eight years old
you say we worship death when someone is
about to die we often want to know what
their last words will be we want to know
for several reasons
mostly it seems like we want to know if
they see anything special if they can
see through the veil between life and
the afterlife and tell us what is there
maybe they think they see their mother
or father or long-dead friends maybe the
afterlife is one big happy reunion that
lasts forever
who knows we don't but maybe even more
important we want to hear
their last words and so that ties into
well first of all i want to thank you
for these books and i want to thank you
for your vulnerability and your honesty
one of my missions and you know god
knows if we're successful
uh you know that'll be worth all the
effort that we put into it but like
suicide and academia
is not a small problem and you know i've
kind of taken it upon because i was
affected so deeply by the suicide of
of many people that i've known um you
know not not
you know an abnormal amount but but
certainly my closest you know father
figure like mentor
andrew lang at caltech as i described uh
you know when we had a podcast together
um
but you know if we can prevent it i
think you're so honest in your writing
uh but one thing i feel is like if
people sat down to write what i call the
or what's known as an ethical will i
feel like it could be
a tool it could be like what al alfred
nobel saw
when he wrote his will you know and he
saw what happened when his brother was
mistaken
uh for for him and and his and his death
was being celebrated
uh as i described and i wonder like what
you think about
in terms of your ethical will and this
is a concept in judaism but everybody
can do barack obama has written one
um and that's kind of like what wisdom
or inheritance of values do you most
want to communicate
and um and i really want to encourage
people to actually physically do it in
the spirit of
of you know choosing themselves even if
they don't publish it there are tools
and places to publish it but
i feel like if people sat down and
thought about like what is your not your
material because someone could be broke
and that might be the reason that
they're
considering such awful things um and
tragic uh to people
but if they thought about their ethical
will i wonder you know if that would not
maybe make them reconsider and reach out
for help but first what would you leave
in your ethical not your material will
well
it's interesting because there's all
sorts of values that you could say
are like first order in the sense that
okay i want people to be um i feel like
i'm
an honest person i want my kids to be
honest i want people to be honest
i feel like you know treat people
you the most important you know
statement in every religion is treat
people how
you would want to be treated you know so
there's all that
but then i think there's something that
people don't think of
as much and and it really comes
to four right now in this time where
everything's so polarized like on every
single issue
just people arguing all day long on
social media and with their friends
with their family and so on i think
there's a certain
um ethical aspect
to being detached from
uh from everything that's going on
so it doesn't mean you don't care like i
care about all the issues that are
happening
i care about people dying from a
pandemic i care about
black lives matter but there's lots of
issues in the world like right now
there's a genocide happening in yemen
for instance it's not in the news at all
it's never in the news there's a whole
big thing happening there
and but it's because people attack
people
there's a certain energy that these
issues have in the media and on social
media so you get attached to them
and it's even considered bad if you
don't get polarized in one way or the
other
but i think i would encourage people
to do really what's what i try to do
which is
be a little bit detached from
all of these arguments to avoid anger
to avoid putting energy you know you
don't want any of these issues
to take up mental real estate like if i
focus on one issue so much that i get
angry about it
and i'm fighting on twitter and i'm
thinking about it
it doesn't mean i'm going to solve the
problem it doesn't mean i'm going to
have any solutions any more than i would
have
but if you could just take a step back
be detached
focus on your own health okay instead of
obsessively reading
cnn i'm gonna exercise and i'm gonna eat
well and i'm gonna sleep well and i'm
gonna
talk to my kids and i'm gonna talk to my
friends and spouse and
and um i'm gonna acknowledge i can't
control
this situation so it's not really that
important for me
to express my opinion everywhere so be
detached
you'll actually find you're much more
creative
and who knows what the outcomes of that
will be that you might have much more
impact on the world
by not just um wholesale
selling your mental real estate to every
issue that the
that's a headline in the media that week
focusing on your own
health and creativity and spirituality
and
and relationships and then you have your
all your mental real estate back
and that's how you can make the most
beneficial impact on the world
whatever it is who knows what it is um
but i think
that's that's what i would say to that
that's and that's a sort of a choose
yourself kind of
philosophy which people could say
choosing yourself isn't that selfish
no if you're sick in bed and if you're
not or if you're or if you're in toxic
relationships or
you're on an airplane and that loses
oxygen what are you supposed to do
yeah you put the oxygen mask on yourself
and that's how you save your baby
so you know people forget that in daily
life and i think that's
such an important ethical concept and
then actually people it's
counterintuitive because many people
think the opposite
so uh so i would say i would say if i
was going to have something that's a
little bit different than what they're
hearing from everywhere else is that
that's what it would be
great so continuing with this theme um
going forward the question that i ask
all my guests to
answer is um in under a minute can you
provide
a scheme to unify uh high energy quantum
mechanics with general relativity
uh using tetsorial calculus in under 14
dimensions
uh uh yeah it's a
it's a giant simulation and they threw
that in
in the operating system but our code
can't access the operating system
exactly oh wow you first double phd when
it
i got it okay got it too okay no
seriously uh if you look in the chat box
i
i sent you two videos these are monolith
scenes from 2001 a space odyssey and you
know our
podcast uh at the arthur c clarke center
derives from one of us or arthur c
clarke's laws that i'll get to in a
minute
but uh but the famous monolith scene
from 2001 is sort of ambiguous it makes
you ask questions why are they doing
this at the very first scene the second
link i sent you uh which i'll put in the
show now it's a black monolith is found
by these
you know primates in africa uh
presumably uh thousands of years ago
or billions of years ago millions of
years ago perhaps
and these monoliths then appear later
the first link i sent you uh links to
when they find on the moon
yeah and these are like devices that are
maybe warnings or maybe
oracles and kind of giving information
and and what i want to ask you is what
now we're we talked about
ethical uh you know spiritual kind of uh
energy you want to send to the future
what material thing what signature you
know of
of our existence of your existence would
you want to put in a billion-year-old
time capsule to be discovered by some
you know future civilization
oh yeah um
you know i'm it's weird because i'm a
very uh
minimalist in the way i live like you
know for a long time i lived with no
belongings at all except when i could
fit into a carry-on bag and i
i didn't even rent or own i just lived
in airbnbs so whenever i think of like
objects to give or get it's like almost
like this blind spot for me
uh so i i don't know the
i don't know the answer to that question
i don't know if i would
care about uh a future civilization
so a minimalist and one in the things i
care about you're gonna yeah
you'll save on postage to the future too
that's right um
last question now we've gone two
questions into the deep future now i
want to go
into the past so the the title of the
podcast into the impossible it derives
from sir arthur's
uh so-called third law which is uh after
the second law which is for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert
i'm sure i love that one encountered one
uh first one being
uh for uh for any sufficiently advanced
technology or any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable
from magic uh and then the la this third
law
is uh is is one that's uh really
quite interesting and in fact it caused
the caused us to choose it for the name
of this podcast and that is
the only way of discovering the limits
of the possible is to venture
a little way past them into the
impossible so i want to ask
advice to your former self what thing
what aspect what what
mystery of life if you will seemed
impossible when you were 20 something
that now makes perfect sense because you
had that
experience of going into the impossible
i mean i guess a lot of a lot of
different things
which is uh i mean i i mean i have like
some
some uh simple examples like as i learn
new skills i always experiment
to get out of my comfort zone bit by bit
to learn that's my whole
philosophy of learning is to experiment
rather than deliberate practice
but um uh
i think my for me
i didn't know and this is very
vulnerable but i didn't know it was
i was dealing with this but i think
simply having
confidence in myself was impossible for
me
until recently no matter what i did no
matter what successes i had
i was always felt like i had to
pander or or show people some
other version of myself than who i was
in order for them
to like me so just simply being myself
was a very impossible thing for me you
know
even 10 15 years ago what's done it for
you i mean
being a best-selling author you've
gotten into good shape i can tell
since i saw you last you're definitely
living
living much more healthy nowadays uh
getting married i mean what what do you
attribute it to
i think being
being disgusted with most things like
realizing that i don't really need
i don't really need to have status for
myself but nor do i need to assume
everyone else has so much
greater status over me and so just being
like disgusted with most things in the
world
has given me um uh
uh you know a sense that i don't really
need to like
try to convince anybody that i'm good
that's like a negative answer but at the
same time yeah
knowing that i can go broke repeatedly
and
come back from that knowing that i could
um have
horrible disastrous situations in my
personal life
and i could come back from it no matter
what happens to me i know i could
bounce back and so after that i just
don't care
anymore if someone doesn't think highly
of me that i
wanted them to think highly of me then
they were not the right person for me
and that's always usually
advice people give but i wasn't really
living that advice
yeah i mean uh you're kind of the the
wikipedia look up
table shows you under resiliency i think
uh you've got
you've come through so much and you've
been so successful but you know the most
important thing i want to thank you for
for influencing to the good so many
people i know you said there's so many
bad things in the world
i think that there are so many bad
people in the world i think the world is
a beautiful
magical place and i know you're i kind
of see you as this as the schroedinger's
cat you know you're kind of like the
most pessimistic optimist or the most
optimistic pessimist that i know
um and that's a trait that i associate
with success because the hardest thing
in life is to maintain that
schrodinger's like balance like
why is it so easy to be polarized
because you're polarized it's
a stable equilibrium you're like oh
they're um that's why you see people
they become religious they go all the
way in or they they renounce their all
their faith all the way out
um but it's very hard to be at the top
of that hill because any spike
perturbation any gust of wind
you're going to be displaced you're
going to be unstable you're going to be
falling free falling through
life and so people like to do what we
call physical collapse the wave function
you know
what is it is it a live cat or is it a
dead cat but no
sometimes you have to live with that
uncertainty and and by by
feeling that uncertainty and those you
see that eric weinstein talks about this
and like
why are people so polarized about
abortion like i'm not gonna get
political i never
i always say you know my podcast is
completely apolitical because nobody
looks up and says i hate that
constellation over there that freaking
constellation
sucks i hate it um pro andromeda
but but but that's a good example like
just as a to mention like i have a
business partner on
on the investing side of my life and
we've worked together since 1999 so 21
years
and uh i'm pro-choice
and he is religiously pro-life as is
half the country half the country's one
half the country still and i always tell
people
we've never once had an argument we've
and we've discussed pro-choice pro-life
and
uh and you know we've had disagreements
on business but we always just
was disagreement's different than
arguing this is where
you kind of don't want to rent mental
real estate to
things that aren't important like i'll
listen to him he knows where i stand we
don't
argue and um and move on and he he
connects the dots his way i connect the
dots
my way and my whole view is is
on optimism versus pessimism is that
it doesn't really matter so much as much
as it is
that we like you say we become
in in the not knowing like
we be we be comfortable with uncertainty
so let's just take and i'll take this
hot potato
issue it's uncertain what the right
thing is
ethically morally religiously whatever
on biologically on pro-choice versus
pro-life
is there a heartbeat in the first second
is there a heartbeat after eight months
like nobody
right there's a line there no one knows
where it is and no one even tries to
define it
it's beyond science somehow but but it's
not beyond legal i'm pro-choice
but uh the key for me is not to convince
anyone because i'm not
the key for me is for people to be calm
about the uncertainty
and that's what i like to always do in
my books
even in my comedy is just to kind of
diffuse
the polarization a little bit yeah yeah
eric eric just to get close out that i
didn't go with eric weinstein you know
he says like
nobody says that life uh begins before
conception right like
when the husband and wife are on the
couch before anything happens no one
says oh there's a life right and nobody
disagrees that there's a life
after the baby's born i mean some uh the
guy at
what's his name at the princeton
university um who claims that there
should be some choice anyway the
audience is screaming at me
but um but nobody disagrees that it's
alive after it's born
so it's in that intermediate state when
it's not the living cat the dead cat and
you think about that with any super
controvers like i look at it through
that lens
and eric turned me on to it and it's
because the human mind is so
uncomfortable with quantum mechanics
in a sense like and it translates
directly to this notion like
a second amendment like nobody would say
that like no one human being on
in the country should ever have a gun
you know period like even the i don't
know i don't against politics but like
on the other side like no one say like
you have to have a howitzer
and an anti-tank missile in everybody's
garage like no even the nra doesn't
think that right so
so like but in between there's this
quantum superposition where
the human mind just is incapable of of
splitting that difference
and living with it but in the quantum
world you know it doesn't matter the cat
is
live and dead in a certain sense and i
think that just really reflects how
unusual and how uh how and perhaps only
the human mind is capable of
maintaining that dichotomy
simultaneously but it's very hard though
people don't
enjoy that feeling yeah right of
uncertainty
but the thing is here's the the other
question is
you know and i know for the sake of the
the math and the experiment and then
the thought experiment in quantum
mechanics this this
this cat experiment exists but why do we
even care if it's alive or dead
like my whole thing is most things i
don't need to think about
like i don't no one's asking me to make
a supreme court decision
right pro-choice no i say that too i'm
like you know if the higgs boson is like
really important to your daily life you
know consult a therapist because
like yeah exactly yeah and then it might
be but like i'm interested in the higgs
boson just because it's fun
yeah like that's a fun thing right but
it's beyond a certain point you're not
that into like you'd be pursuing it
you know like right it's interesting but
yeah i i got what you're saying and like
okay the pandemic um interested in the
numbers
but like there's more people dying in
other parts of the world right now from
wars that we've started or whatever so
uh
why don't people care about that like
the key is is to not ask
to ask why about the things you're
interested and passionate about
and and but to ask why without caring
about the outcome because we don't know
that's why we're asking why
and then to not ask why about things
that are much more easier to be
detached from like okay i don't want my
dad to die of
coronavirus so dad be careful
but uh for myself actually i don't
really care so much
the new york knicks you know center you
know he's probably not going to get it
right so just to close out and one one
final anecdote related to both father's
day
and to abortion on my 30th birthday you
were aborted
my father said you know i believe in
abortion up until
the 90th trimester you know so yeah
great that's great dad thanks
okay i had a i once had a bit similar to
that
uh oncoming it did not work because no
matter what there was no way to make it
work
you can't make jokes about like the
holocaust or you know like
oh i make talks about the holocaust yes
okay well
we'll keep that let's save that for uh
the next part if no
i'll i'll just give you the the clue
because this is this is a
huge material in this one it's like it's
like when you find
a mine that you could drill where
there's huge you realize oh my gosh this
is the biggest gold mine in the world
it's it's exciting so on google maps
everything is reviewed every location
you can write a review for
so auschwitz has thousands of reviews
right so just that concept is funny
and there's when when you actually read
the reviews it's just like a gold mine
yeah i know
i went down to 9 11 uh to the you know
ground zero and i'm like 44 bucks
like it's just you know like but people
are paying it right and
and has reviews too exactly exactly what
i found uh well james speaking of
fathers
uh yeah i want to wish you a happy
father's day you too man
i hope you get uh a couple of moxies uh
for yourself you know keep feeling keep
you busy i know you're lonely sometimes
too
i want to thank you seriously from the
depths of my heart for all the good that
you
didn't know that you were doing in my
life i'm just like thank you brian i
mean you're a
superstar so it's a high praise to for
you to say that
well thank you so much for coming on i
hope we can do it again sometime
yeah definitely thank you
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable
from magic
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe
comment share rate and review for a
chance to win a free copy of our most
recent guest's newest book
send a screenshot of your review to info
imagine.ucsd.edu
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes
for more information go to
imagination.ucsd.edu
find us on twitter at imagineucsd
watch us on youtube listen on itunes
into the impossible is a production of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination in the division of physical
sciences
at the university of california san
diego
eric very director brian keating
co-director